what up Crips and bloods my name is ryan
right and I Mariano ossory Ariana
fostering my Jewish female friend has
returned oh speaking of Jewish people
existing existence a short sci-fi movie
see Ariana there's this holiday called
Christmas not a part of it we've gone
through this but on Christmas um I made
an announcement that if you're a
subscriber and you actually create short
films or sketches you should submit them
and I'll review them with a guest by man
named Josh Robertson channel watermelon
films let's see if this is worth it
we're gonna be honest if this is some
like arty stuff or funny stuff will
laugh artsy will see it better be good
that's all that matters get ready for
some raw judgment a lot of pressure it
shouldn't be a lot of pressure you're in
the big leagues now reacts amen no one
wants bad free content it's cool shot
can't you see the camera flashing yeah
let's go yeah good reflection oh really
alien vibe going off that's his father I
Betty hard as data beans do you know
this is that Lord it might be him I
wonder if we're talking to children to
pick up happened o.o out loud okay so
this is like one of those study pieces
study pieces I just want to get you
nervous that's why I'm commenting on
everything
he hasn't bruce willis vibe yeah you
mean the actor yeah Oh kind of not as
charming or it's not wrong is the moral
of that ok so it's night time we've
established that the moon Oh Lou
you know man you got some cool shots in
here like the cinematography is not bad
for a film you did it with just you in
your death
Wow
have to be patient with amateur
filmmaking they try to be deep
philosophical and tell a story without
dialogue Thank You sandy dialogue I
don't think what I got you we got you
well it looks like a giant or that's
just the sand I thought it looks like it
yeah I'm like a beach person definitely
that's honor that no that's like I don't
know what beach that is yeah
please
that's the show he's been walking for a
while right I understand um if this
happened to you you'd be like what no
have you would just walk on the sand
well it looks like a very peaceful place
I mean if an alien abducted me there I'd
be sweet like thank you so far he's had
very little reaction
it's hurting it a lot thank you probably
not as dad we have a bet
I know you're trying to tell us
something I'm not quite getting it good
shot though it was cool yep someone got
in a tree provide for visual identity
if you always working I don't think so
they probed him I get it Rob yeah aliens
proked him and now there's a alien
growing inside of him there's nothing to
tell you that he got abducted at the
beach and they took advantage of him to
you don't know that he got taken
advantage of certainly he's responding
as if he did hide in your own backyard
what is in existence right now
I
huh so there must be a section that
teleports you faster to the beach you
know that's what I'm gathering is that
there's a certain area that you walk
into damn I like that teleportation Zuma
Beach Clark Zuma Beach
what oh it's over quite the plotline you
have everybody start positives they say
in communication you should say at least
three positive things before getting
criticism that's what you're about to
hear from me right now ryan right
leadership communication skills
one-on-one positives one you had some
pretty good shots in there buddy yeah
there were some good shots really liked
it too location the beach did look
appealing I was like I'd like to go to
the beach sometime that feels relaxing
yeah it's like a good place to shoot
three dig too much um your dad did a
great job I bet it's not your dad he's
gonna totally blow job bro somebody
different well broken here's the thing
with it I don't know what it's about and
I don't feel like a lot of people will
get what it's about even if I wasn't you
know just talking a lot of the time come
watching this and I'm like okay you're
doing that thing that filmmakers like to
do like no dialogue let's just do
imagery and let the that tell the story
however I don't see a plot line here
other than some guy disappears to some
place that gives us no clue as to where
he is it's just bad then he goes back
however you're good at shooting you're
practicing so i wouldn't say quit on
your dreams right and you made something
exactly you didn't make a complete
something see and that's what counts I
think that's great so stay in there stay
motivated and also um you know thrown a
sex scene every once in a while that's
not if you want to talk about existence
that's it I don't know how old you are
but you said you went to college here in
the description box so you know what sex
must be like not necess throw it in
there have your dad act with the woman
ha it's not tell us if it's your dad I'm
very curious now it's not his that Bruce
Willis is his father
now do you want to join in the joke now
that I included yours Bruce Willis now
do you want to kind of play along yeah
it's your dad yeah they say um two or
three with a common purpose nothing's
impossible the Bible yeah get with it oh
my god like not even my identifier at
all watermelon films thanks for
submitting that hope we weren't too hard
on you if you do another one submitted
our way it better be better that's all
I'm saying just have it improve you
don't want to take a step back you know
what I mean Brett you want to keep
moving forward take the criticism see
what you agree with see what you don't
agree but what's your criticism my
criticism is learn to be clear about
your plot lines and make sure to throw
in a sex scene because if you're gonna
talk about existence that's a big part
that we don't talk about you want to be
bold and brave and cover new ground in
territory being an edgy filmmaker that's
what's going to make you successful lars
von trier if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today and become a
reject do it by yourself kid and Ariana
ba Sri she has social media like a lot
of other people you could catch her on
her facebook facebook.com slash Ariana
my fanpage what's your fan okay you
could catch her on her facebook fanpage
my name what's your fan page called
Ariana ba Sri also facebook.com slash
Ariana ba Sri I'm not positive that's
where I will thank you it'll be in the
description box for that but then don't
try to be my friend be my fan I mean
well you have two separate pages in your
fan your luggage it was try to be my
friend and I just don't know them I know
so your fan page was retitled tell your
friend a good case for my age it does
comedian under it thank you that's what
I was looking for that way people can
search it